Everyone fantasizes about the glamor and glitz
that comes with being an actor. The stardom,
the seven-figure paychecks, and romantic relationships
that blossom with your co-stars but sometimes
being an actor isn’t so glamorous. Some
actors sacrifice more than they should, taking
it as far as putting their lives in danger
just for a chance at winning that illustrious
Oscar gold.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Actors
Who Took Their Movie Roles Way Too Far.
Robert De Niro in Cape Fear
When Martin Scorsese cast Robert De Niro as
a psychopathic rapist in his 1991 remake of
the same name, “Cape Fear” he knew he
would get an amazing performance. De Niro
already worked as a taxi driver for twelve-hour
days for weeks to prepare for Scorsese’s
“Taxi Driver.” So it was no surprise to
the director with the extremes De Niro took
to prepare for this role. De Niro paid a dentist
$20,000 to grind and stain his teeth to look
like a man who was in prison for years. The
role won him Oscar and Golden Globe nominations
giving the actor a wide grin.
Rooney Mara in The Girl withtheDragon
Tattoo
David Fincher asked Rooney Mara to change
her body to fit the character of antisocial,
hostile Lisbeth Salander in 2011’s “The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo.” He put her
on a strict diet and asked her to live in
Stockholm on her own for weeks before production
began. He even had her dye her hair black,
chop down her long bangs and bleach her eyebrows
white. What she did on her own was add numerous
piercings to her body to get more into the
character. Her eyebrow, nose, lips and even
her nipple! That’s dedication.
Christian Bale in The Machinist
It’s hard to believe that the muscle toned
Christian Bale in the Batman Trilogy is the
same man in 2004’s “The Machinist”.
Bale lost over 63 pounds for his role in the
psychological thriller that nearly cost him
his life. He lost another 20 pounds from what
his nutritionist said was safe and wanted
to loose another 5 but was told he would die
if he did. He survived off eating one apple
and a can of tuna fish daily for weeks leading
up to shooting. To make matters worse, he
smoked cigarettes to curve his hunger in this
8.2 million dollar grossing flop.
Billy Bob Thornton in Sling Blade
Billy Bob Thornton felt that he had a lot
to prove in his directorial debut with 1996’s
“Sling Blade”. The American drama film
set in rural Arkansas is lead by main character
Karl Childers, an intellectually disabled
man played by Thornton. Thornton immersed
himself into the role causing many filmgoers
not to recognize him on screen. To achieve
his characters peculiar shuffle, Thornton
added broken pieces of glass to his shoes
to ensure continuity throughout shooting.
Giving a new meaning the word, “Cut!”
on set.
Natalie Portman in Black Swan
Natalie Portman took herself from actress
to believable ballerina for her role in “Black
Swan”, by doing extensive workouts. Portman
said, "We usually started by swimming a mile
a day, doing the front crawl and breast stroke.
Then we'd do two hours of ballet exercises
and resistance work." This was not her only
form of preparation, she even held to a stringent
diet to accomplish the figure she required
in her Oscar winning role.
Daniel Day-Lewis in The Crucible
We all know of the irregular ways Daniel Day-Lewis
prepares for his roles but 1996’s “The
Crucible” might be the oddest. To prepare
for the role of 17th-century farmer John Proctor,
Day-Lewis spent the summer before filming
on location at Hog Island, northern Massachusetts.
He rode into work on a brown horse, lived
without running water or electricity and helped
build the sets for the production. He even
ditched the power tools of today and used
the tools of the 17th century.
Halle Berry in Jungle Fever
The talented Halle Berry has always been a
gifted actress but was over shadowed by her
stunning looks for many years. Before winning
in Oscar in 2001’s “Monster Ball” she
garnered her first critical fame in 1991’s
“Jungle Fever”. The director couldn’t
see past her looks and felt she was too attractive
for the role as a crack addictive prostitute
that lived on the streets. So during her 10
days of filming she never bathed or showered
to help portray the dirt her character lived
in. This triggered her to apologize to her
co-stars those last days of shooting but she
proved her talents and quieted her director.
Heath Ledger in The Dark Knight
Heath Ledger knew that the Joker wasn’t
a character he that could easily get into
and even reached out to Jack Nicholson for
help. Nicholson told him that he’d go crazy
reaching the levels he needed to for the role.
Ledger locked himself into a hotel room for
four weeks with no contact to the outside
world to prepare. He wrote in a personal diary
in which he wrote really insane things and
slept for only 2 hours per day.
Margot Robbie in Suicide Squad
Margot Robbie is quickly becoming on of Hollywood’s
most bankable stars but if acting doesn’t
work out maybe she can use her new skill as
an Olympic swimmer. Robbie learned to hold
her breath underwater for over five minutes
to perform a fight scene in “Suicide Squad”.
The actress was competitive with her stunt
double and wanted to prove her mad skills.
Luckily she stopped at five minutes and went
on to finish some other crazy scenes alongside
Jared Leto.
Shia LaBeouf in Fury
Here is one time an actor joined the US National
Guard and joined a religion to prepare for
a movie. Director David Ayer told his cast
he needed his actors to give him their all
for 2012’s “Fury. They did, but Shia LaBeouf
went the furthest. He went as far as to cut
his face numerous times and even got a tattoo
to give a more realistic portrayal on screen.
That’s not where the actor stopped, he also
had a tooth removed and he kept his personal
hygiene to a bare minimum. Ayer loved this
dedication and even had his actors’ fist
fighting on set every day.
What do you think of our video? Did we skip
over any of your favorite actors that took
their movie roles way too far? Sound off in
the comments below and be sure to subscribe
to our channel for more fun videos! Thanks
for watching!